on the weekend
a group of people
called on others to go and arrest the
police members of the peterborough
police department but in the end it was
some of those protesters who were
arrested
at peterborough's police station an
ordinary monday what unfolded here on
saturday was not
the weekly anti-government protest
downtown took a twist after this woman
romana d'dullo in the motor home called
on people to arrest members of the local
police they 100 percent believed that
they could arrest the police and i
wouldn't be surprised if they tried
again a group went to peterborough
police headquarters and some tried to
carry out the wishes of a woman who
calls herself the queen of canada she's
espoused anti-government anti-vaccine
views for months
people really believe in what she says
her followers do to the point where they
you know quit paying their bills because
she told them that they no longer have
to pay them and some are losing their
homes eventually two of the protesters
were arrested and held for a court
appearance not good not good many in
peterborough have grown tired of the
protests
stupid but arresting the police is
something new the obstruction
potentially of the police movement
throughout the police department is
likely what caused the issue
it's either insanity or treason but this
university of pittsburgh professor says
this kind of government effort must be
taken seriously even if it appears on
the fringes they want to replace it with
some creation of their own and i don't
think we should ignore people who are
making steps or strides to actually
carry out these ideas
this story is still developing just a
little over an hour ago the peterborough
police chief put out a video statement
they've now arrested a third suspect a
31-year-old man charged with three
charges in connection with what happened
at the police station on the weekend
adding to two other men who are charged
they're in their 50s plus the ontario
special investigations unit they're
investigating because of injuries that
were sustained by one of the people who
was arrested so police asking for videos
asking for evidence there will likely be
more charges and there may be more
situations like what we saw here in
peterborough on the weekend stay tuned
tracy all right sean thank you for
staying on top of all of that for us
shawn o'shea live in peterborough for us
thanks sean